[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: Hello,
can everybody hear me?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: Great.
Good afternoon and welcome
to Talks at Google today.
I want to say a special welcome
to all our external guests, who
made an effort to
come all the way here.
I hope you have a
really good time.
Today's talk is
particularly special to me,
because for the first time ever
two employee resource groups
have come together to present
this talk in front of you.
Gayglers and Allies
and Women at Google.
Big round of applause for
them for all the great work
they do for us.
So today, we will
touch on a few things.
One of them is resilience.
Building resilience can be one
of the most difficult lessons
people learn in the formative
years of their career.
The ability to
cope, bounce back,
and the will to go
through adversity
is something that is
different for everyone.
Some people exceed, some
manage, some simply fail.
How can we develop a sense
of purpose for ourselves
and make sure that the workplace
at Google, or wherever you're
working, is a place
where you feel safe,
and you feel like that you
can be yourself and bring
your whole selves to work?
Without further
ado, I would like
to introduce you to
our guest speaker
today, the CEO of Stonewall,
a nonprofit organization
in the UK, who are doing
some amazing work fighting
against homophobic bullying in
schools amongst other things.
So give a warm
welcome to Ruth Hunt.
[APPLAUSE]
RUTH HUNT: Thank you very much.
And thank you for having
me here this afternoon.
I am afraid I don't use
PowerPoint because I
think it's really dull.
And I also don't
write long speeches.
Mainly because I'm very
dyslexic, so reading
long speeches is impossible.
And also because I
really like to panic
that the Stonewall comes to,
because they never quite know
what I'm going to say.
And I treat every space as if
it's off record and informal.
So I'm a very honest speaker.
So I'm not even aware
that you're filming.
But that means if I
speak in universities,
I'm expected to
provide a content note,
because we now live
in a culture where
I have to warn people
about what I might say,
which also makes it very
difficult for my style.
Because who knows?
I'm going to talk a little
bit today about Stonewall's
history, the history of
the gay rights movement,
and the trans movement,
and the lesbian movement,
and the bisexual movement,
and how my career has kind of
dovetailed throughout all
that, and some of the things
I've learned along the way.
And I hope that at
my stage in life--
I'm 37 at the moment--
I've still got a
huge amount to learn.
If you'll be forgiving
of the things
I don't know and kind of
see me for where I'm at.
So Stonewall was set up in
1989, in response to Section 28.
And Section 28 was a
piece of legislation
that prevented the promotion
of homosexuality in schools.
It came at a time where
culturally Britain
was in quite a complex place
about sexual orientation.
And I think it's
worth just pausing
and going back to what we've
been celebrating this week.
Fifty years ago, gay men were
persecuted, actively imprisoned
for who they loved.
And we talk a lot about love,
more on that in a moment.
But actually for
what they were doing
quite a lot of the
time in toilets,
but also for who they loved,
and were persecuted and told
that who they were was illegal.
So there are
generations of older men
now, men who have sex
with men, gay men, who
were told that what
they were was completely
illegal and unlawful.
In around the 1970s,
what we were seeing
was that transgender
people were pretty much
able to fully transition
to their desired gender
without much fuss
from the state.
So if you're rich enough,
if you're confident enough,
you could pretty
much transition.
That changed when
a woman attempted
to get a better settlement
for divorcing her husband,
and the high court judge ruled
that their marriage was invalid
because she wasn't
really a woman.
And thus, every
informal mechanism
that existed for trans
people faded away.
In the 70s, things started
to seem to be changing.
We had more civil
rights movements,
more things happening.
But then HIV hit.
And what we saw was a
significant decimation
of the lesbian
and gay community.
And men were dying,
absolutely just dying.
And the state didn't respond.
The state did not respond
to this absolutely national
traumatic event.
And it was lesbians
running clinics
with gay men, who
were running clinics
for HIV positive from South
Africa, HIV positive women, HIV
drug dealers.
You know, there was
a much greater sense
of a community and desperation.
Section 28 then came in.
So section 28 came in
when I was seven years old
and I was at school.
And Section 28 was the
kind of third big bit
of rubbish to hit a
community that was already
feeling pretty rubbish.
And I just give that
context, because that's quite
a hard core legacy.
For any young LGBT kid growing
up, they know that legacy,
they know that history.
When I went to school, we didn't
talk about gay stuff at all.
I realized I was different
when I was about 12,
which is very young.
It's even young in
these terms really.
But I was always a tomboy.
I was always different,
a bit other, a bit odd.
I was never very cool.
And never really fitted in.
I didn't really, and I still
don't, like small talk.
I find the banality of talking
unnecessary nonsense deeply
frustrating.
That doesn't make me a
particularly good lobbyist,
more on that later.
So I was always a bit queer,
a bit different, a bit other.
When I was 12, I
realized I was gay.
And I went to Cardiff Library.
I was brought up in Cardiff.
And I read "The
Well of Loneliness,"
and "Orange is not
the only Fruit,"
because those are the two
books on the lesbian section.
Now, if you know anything
about lesbian fiction,
"The Well of
Loneliness" and "Orange
is not the only Fruit,"
the single most depressing,
soul destroying books
in the entire world--
they are really not top 10 tips
on how to meet a girlfriend
and kiss her.
It's a bit more
hardcore than that.
So "Well of Loneliness"
doesn't end well.
"Orange is not the
only Fruit" gave me
a love of Jeanette
Winterson, and gave me
a language and a narrative of
how to do dating from 15 to 22,
that meant most of my
adolescent relationships
were really intense and full
of very, very good constructed
sentences, but not a lot of fun.
So Cardiff was pretty harsh.
And my parents were
desperately, desperately keen
that I didn't let myself down.
So they had come from
nontraditional backgrounds.
My mum had trained
to be a nurse at 18.
Then she was a midwife.
Then she did a PGCE.
Then she did an MSC.
Then she did her PhD when
the second child was coming.
And then--
And so she was a teacher
in [INAUDIBLE],, and very,
very pleased to have got there.
But if she'd had a
different education,
she could have been a doctor.
That was her whole,
and is her whole story.
If she hadn't been one of five
children who was the girl,
and made to bring up
her four brothers,
she could have been a doctor.
That was absolutely
how she saw it.
And my dad-- and I
think that's true.
And my dad dropped
out of school.
And he trained to
be an architect
by working as a jobbing
lad in different shops.
So they done good, and they
had money, not that much money,
but they'd done good.
But they did not want their
kids to in any way not
have the most opportunity.
So me and my brother we just
had to work really, really hard.
And it didn't really
matter what we did,
as long as we
worked really hard.
So when my parents learned
that I was different,
and was coming out,
they were so frightened.
They were so frightened
that I would experience
huge levels of discrimination.
That I wouldn't get
into university.
That I would struggle, that
I would really struggle.
Their fear was absolutely
palpable and contagious.
Section 28 didn't help that.
The lack of visibility of
lesbian, gay, and bisexual,
and trans issues on
television didn't help that.
The lack of employers
talking about these things
didn't help that.
The fact that midwives
were being trained then
and didn't even talk
about lesbian parenting
didn't help that.
That absence, even
if it was neutral,
was deeply damaging to two
people who were just scared.
And I, being assertive,
clear, teenager-ee
was just like, well, I am gay.
Have you done anything gay?
No, but I am.
I read "Well of Loneliness."
So I was kind of
much more defiant
than I probably
should have been.
And what I see now with
Stonewall's youth work
is they're much more relaxed
about where they might end up
on that journey.
And I probably would
have been more relaxed
had I been growing up now.
So a real tension.
And Stonewall was kind of
just forming and Stonewall
in those days.
It was a [INAUDIBLE]
organization,
lobbying and campaigning.
At 16, I moved to Birmingham.
Now when you move to Birmingham
from a small Welsh school that
was mainly boys, and you
know that you're gay,
Birmingham has the potential
to be quite a high risk taking
period in one's life, I think.
And I really enjoyed Birmingham.
I also started
writing for something
called "Diva Magazine," which
is a magazine for lesbians.
And in those days, I
was getting 400 pounds
a month check sent to me.
And that so much money
when I was basically on 15
quid a week, you know
paper round or something.
So I was getting these
checks for 400 pounds
and putting it into my instant
savers Abbey National Bank
account.
And my mom found it.
She goes why-- she thought
I was dealing drugs,
because I had all this money and
didn't have much to do with it.
So I had this big blow
up with my parents,
and my parents were like you
cannot, you cannot be gay.
You cannot tell
anyone you're gay.
They will really, really
have a problem with you.
And I was in school, and
I'd been elected head girl,
and the school
said, actually, you
can't be head girl because
we've got 11-year-olds here.
And if they see that
you're head girl,
they might think that your
decisions and choices you make
are the right ones.
So we're going to make
you deputy head girl,
because that's the party one.
And, yeah, that seems
really reasonable to me.
And all I could
hear is my mom going
this is going to get in
your way, get in your way.
And I thought it is.
It's getting in my way.
I've got to be really
careful about this.
And I did a speech at
school, school's speech day
or something.
And my mom was in the queue.
And the woman in front
said to her daughter,
Ruth was very good.
She said yeah, she's gay though.
Oh, it's a shame.
And my mom absolutely
collapsed with anxiety,
and love, and fierceness.
And she didn't know what
to do with that stuff.
And I feel it now.
So she said you're not
going to get into Oxford.
Whatever you do, don't
let them know you're gay--
and don't-- so I
got into Oxford,
but with that voice ringing in
my ear that I wouldn't be OK.
Don't tell anyone.
Now, you can't go
to Oxford and not
tell anyone you're gay, because
that would make you different,
because most people
in Oxford are gay.
So pretty much-- so I
came out straightaway,
became president of
the junior common room,
and then was elected president
of the student union.
So at that stage,
was really learning
how to develop a very strong
narrative about identity,
a real awareness of how fear
gets in the way of you being
able to be yourself, but also
very aware of how utterly
privileged I was.
I was smart, educated, white,
had good chat, could work hard,
I knew all those things.
But what I was very aware
of is how deeply unfair
it is that barriers are
created to people getting on
through fear, and
through discrimination,
and through prejudice,
and through, and through,
and through, and through.
And I'm a good campaigner.
I'm a campaigner.
That's what I learned at Oxford.
I didn't learn how to translate
streets of Old English,
I barely scraped my T1, but I
did learn I was a campaigner.
And on that, when
I left university,
I went and worked in
various different places,
finding my way.
But at 25, when I was 25,
a job came up in Stonewall.
So I started in Stonewall, baby
dike, number three haircut,
20 Marlboro lights.
And when I was-- as the
president of course,
student union president, I got
lots of calls from companies.
We're really interested in you.
I thought you're not.
They never saw me.
It was pre-internet days.
I mean, they saw my CV,
but they didn't know--
I thought, if they
knew who I was.
It was that voice of my
mother ringing in my ear,
you're not going to get on,
you're not going to get a job,
they're not going to like
you, they're not going to--
I thought I can't work for the
big five or wherever they are.
I can't do that.
I am not going to be a good fit.
I did a careers
test, and they said
you should go for the army.
And I laughed, and
laughed, laughed.
Now, actually, I'd have probably
been a good fit for the army.
I mean, the stigmatism and
general day daydreamingness
wouldn't have helped.
But I probably would--
I'm a good leader.
You know, that might
have been a good option.
Any of those companies could
But I ruled myself out, ruled
myself out, ruled myself out.
So I started in Stonewall, baby
dike, 25 years old, 25 staff,
1.4 million at that time.
And Stonewall was
assiduously campaigning for--
what's this counting
down-- oh, no, sorry--
Stonewall was assiduously
assimilationist.
So Stonewall's campaigning.
And we are really good at it.
It was all about saying
gay people are normal,
we're just like you.
We want to pay taxes.
We want to have babies.
We want to get married.
Look how sensible
and normal we are.
We're not going to talk
about sex in toilets.
We're going to talk about love.
We're not going to
talk about complex,
messed up relationships
that everybody has.
We're going to talk about good,
solid, monogamy, and good gays.
We're going to talk
about nice gays.
We're going to talk about
the gay men who not too camp.
We're going to talk about the
women who are not too butch.
really nice side of being gay.
And that was the mission.
The mission was in
every boardroom,
in every institution, gay
people are just like you.
And I really struggled a bit.
You know, I really--
I softened up, I wore
blouses, my hair was longer.
And I thought I'm not going
to get on here, actually.
I can never be chief executive,
because the politicians
won't like me enough.
I'm too, I'm too--
I'm not neat enough.
So ruling myself out
even at that stage,
in a place where I should
have been most comfortable.
Now history will judge
whether Stonewall
was right to pursue this kind
of assiduously assimilationist
approach.
We have the best
legislation in relation
to sexual orientation
in the world.
And we got that
because while we were
changing the law about
lesbians having babies,
they didn't notice.
Because they just looked this
nice shiny thing over here.
You know, the polite
courteous approach
has been really effective.
And as a change agent, I totally
believe that the biggest power
influence, our employers.
You know, when Barclays puts
MX on their credit cards
to acknowledge
non-binary identities,
that is more powerful than
anything Stonewall can ever do.
When Accenture
work in the Sudan,
and talk about same
sex relationships,
that's more powerful.
You know, all these things,
these power agencies,
these centers of power are
changing and falling away.
Capitalism is changing.
Social change is at the heart
of any capitalist state movement
right now.
The need to work with
everyone, and be courteous,
and work well, and match
them, and match their style
is essential.
And I still do that.
I can move in any
space, in any place.
But what I had to learn when
I became chief executive,
is that actually we couldn't
leave people behind.
So I did seven different
jobs in Stonewall.
And part of my narrative is I'm
very loyal to the institutions
I belong to.
Oxford University is
absolutely my family.
Stonewall is my family.
Quite what I'm going to
do next, I don't know.
But I know I will need
to belong to something.
I will need to belong
to an organization that
feels like that family,
because that's how I work.
I can't dip in and out.
I have to feel part of it.
Six jobs-- Stonewall's now 120
staff and 7.5 million turnover.
We take no core
government funding.
We take a bit for projects.
Very diverse income portfolios.
So being chief
executive of Stonewall,
I have to be quite shrewd
businesswoman, to be honest.
I have to understand
profit and loss.
where income comes from,
and how much we can spend,
and how much we can save.
I have to understand all that.
And then I have
to be a chief gay.
And that kind of professional
gay role is quite hard.
It's quite hard
to juxtapose that
with actually managing
a small enterprise,
with all the things
that come with that.
And it's a big ask.
And one of the things
that I was actually
committed to in 2014 when
I became chief executive
was quite major cultural change.
I wanted us to be
able to do both.
I wanted us to be able to
work with the Archbishop
of Canterbury.
My three clients, Archbishop
of Canterbury, Premier League
footballers, and
security services.
You know, my ability to
navigate in those three spaces
is absolutely crucial to
my ability to do my job.
I want that.
But I want the
queer non-binary kid
who's bullied because he
doesn't know what he's
doing to be part of that too.
So I wanted trans people to
be involved in Stonewall.
Much of our big
work at the moment
is around black, Asian,
and minority communities
coming into Stonewall.
I want people who
are left behind
to feel part of Stonewall.
And that require a
significant cultural change.
And that's where the
stuff got scary for me.
That's where I suddenly
stopped coasting, and was like,
OK, now I'm a little
bit out of my depth.
How do you do
culture change when
you've been part of an
institution for that long,
when you've learned to
another CEO for that long?
How do you challenge?
So this is what I've learned.
I've learned that people emulate
the style of leadership they
deem to be successful and
they generally do it badly.
The whole issue of
inclusion is about people
trying to be something that
they're not all the time.
Diversity is something
that people obsess about.
They talk a lot about diversity.
Diversity should
be your outcome.
So even in an
organization where you
have a Benetton advert of staff,
if they are all desperately
trying to please me, and
act like I want them to act,
their different
experience is irrelevant.
So the first thing
I had to do is
give up power and stop being
a bit of an idiot around that.
I had to actively bring people
in a room who annoyed me.
The second thing I
learned, most people
only like to work with
people who think like them.
It is deeply frustrating
to work with someone
who doesn't think like you,
who thinks differently,
who doesn't get it quite as
fast as you'd like them to,
who doesn't keep
up with you, who
doesn't blow smoke up your
ass in the most polite way
possible.
It is really difficult.
And I see the army, when
I worked with the army,
they are working--
they've been six weeks in a
tin can with two other people.
Of course when there's a
call to go to war in Iraq
they're going to get
those two people that
were in a tin can within six
weeks and only talk to them,
and ignore the trans woman over
there, going, I don't actually
think Iraq can fire
bombs that fast.
No, no one?
OK, bye.
We like to draw people
around us who think like us.
We like to recruit
people who think like us.
And what I realized is what
we were doing at Stonewall
is recruiting in a way that
said look how diverse we are,
but then making them assimilate
into our way of working,
make them think, act, and
work as the Stonewall way.
So I had to throw all that away.
I had to throw all that away.
I had to do a big
culture change.
I had to get rid
of lots of staff
without leaving blood
on the floor, which is,
a bit difficult. All
under scrutiny of a public
who were going well, we're not
ready for a lesbian running
Stonewall, are we?
And who does she think she is?
And she's not very sociable.
And she doesn't drink.
And actually it's gay men
that paid for Stonewall.
Who the hell does
she think she is?
And that level of scrutiny
is pretty relentless.
When you are being held to
account on every social media
platform for everything
you might think or do,
and you're trying to do
a culture change, that's
pretty hardcore.
So that combination--
I was young.
34, I was too young to be
doing some of this stuff,
even though I had
all the chatter.
That is quite hardcore.
So how did I do it?
Well, personally, I
had to really change
how I thought about things.
I had to accept the things
I wasn't so good at.
I had to accept that I
needed people around me who
disagreed with me and
actively make those steps.
And I had to accept
that sometimes I
would get things wrong and how
was I going to handle that.
And I had to make
time for myself.
So I made sure I had all
the things around me,
the staff around me.
The things I did wrong, I
hired people, wrong people,
too quickly.
I should have taken longer,
and hired the right people,
and relaxed a bit about it.
But I had to role
model the behavior
I wanted to see in
Stonewall, which
means I lead the work on
[INAUDIBLE] inclusion.
I lead the work on
trans inclusion.
And I make sure that at
every available opportunity
I'm reiterating our vision,
mission, and values.
So we've got to a stage is
an organization where we
feel much richer as a culture.
But when I look
at organizations,
when I go into
organizations, Stonewall
works with 750
employers, 2,000 schools.
We're out there.
We're doing lots of things.
That chat about
diversity is so dull.
Here's our gay member of
staff, he's really happy.
It's all going really well.
We are fundamentally a
meritocratic organization,
and therefore we don't
need to worry about this.
So what I just want to finish
on is a note about meritocracy.
Meritocracy is an
absolute fallacy.
There is no such
thing as meritocracy.
Because meritocracy
presumes that people
have the same starting
chance in life.
And nobody has the same
starting chance in life.
My ability to do my job was
of course helped by the fact
that I had slightly bonkers
parents, albeit bonkers,
who did love me and
wanted me to do very well,
who gave me a desk
at the age of two
so I could do my homework,
who made sure I had books
around me, who, even though
they were a little bit
tonto at times,
wanted me to do well.
You compare that to a kid
who doesn't have that,
and has no income, and
no access to resources,
and gets to the
same place as me,
double their salary immediately.
Because the lengths they've
gone to get to the same place
as me should tell you more
about their potential than what
I am telling you.
We don't do that.
We don't recognize that people
come from different places
to reach the same place.
And therefore, when we recruit,
we pretend that we are blind.
We don't care if you're
blue, pink, gay, straight,
green, yellow, we just want you
to be the best damn programmer
in the world.
Without realizing that actually
what you're talking about
is not leveling the playing
field and not creating a space.
So the best employers
are starting
talking about potential.
And if I look at MI5, MI5
five looked around the room
and went maybe all these
men in white chinos
with their modern
languages degrees
aren't going to help us
solve Muslim terrorism.
It's like no, no they're not.
But the thing is you
employ more Muslims,
it's all a bit more
difficult, because, yes,
you have to change.
If you want to change
how your staff think,
work, act, and feel, it is not
about putting another chair
around the table.
You have to redesign the table.
You have to create new
ways, and new opportunities,
and new ways of working.
And I adore Google.
But you think you're
so marvelous, my loves.
You really do think
that you are the dogs
bollocks in this regard.
And you do not know how many
people are ruling themselves
out of working with you, how
many people presume that they
will not succeed and do well
with you, how many people are
just thinking that you have to
be a certain type, all be it
a particularly interesting
kooky type, yes.
You will not continue
to succeed if you do not
start thinking differently about
how you bring the people who
live less than a mile
away into this building
to be part of what
you're trying to achieve.
Unless you put social change
at the heart of your mission,
you will very quickly find
that this is becoming outdated.
So that's what I've
learned in my life.
And the last three years
have been pretty hardcore.
I'm immensely proud of
the team at Stonewall.
I'm immensely proud
of what we do.
50% growth in three
years is something
I'm very pleased with.
And I hope that we will continue
to do marvelous things with you
and others.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY:
Thank you, Ruth.
That was very, very good.
So, OK, it's my first
time, so bear with me.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So now onto the next
phase of today's event.
And I would like to
invite Liz Cunningham, who
is director of finance
here at Google,
and Mick Hodgins, who
is director of solutions
and innovations at Google.
[APPLAUSE]
And just a note
to everyone, there
will be time for questions
and answers at the end.
So get those questions ready.
Great, so, welcome everyone.
LIZ CUNNINGHAM: Thank you.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: Please--
LIZ CUNNINGHAM: Thank you, Ruth.
MICK HODGINS: Hi,
Ruth that was great.
I'd just like to,
before we start,
to point out that I
wasn't quite the diversity
hire from within a mile.
Maybe two miles.
RUTH HUNT: Good.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: Great.
I heard this really great quote.
I thought it was great.
It was from Verna Myers,
who was a TED X speaker.
She said diversity is
being invited to a party,
and inclusion is
being asked to dance.
So that made me think that
they really go hand in hand.
So maybe, Liz, you can
tell us a little bit more
about what diversity
and inclusion mean
for you and your org.
LIZ CUNNINGHAM: Yes, I actually
look after the tax team,
so we're probably one of the
least diverse organizations,
because it's actually all women.
We sent the one male
we had off to the US.
So I'm very passionate
about inclusion.
And that's where my
passion really lies.
And inclusion for me
is just making sure
that you're listening to
everybody's perspective.
I look around the team
and broader finance
regularly to make
sure that we're
listening to everybody's voice.
And I've some good
examples, which
I think we'll get
onto later, but where
my voice wasn't heard At times.
And for me, that's
what inclusion is.
It doesn't matter what
your background is.
And I'd encourage people
in the room and managers
to make sure that they are
really conscious, that they're
listening to
everybody in the team,
because everybody's
voice is very important.
I picked up a quote
that Ruth gave.
The need to work with
everyone is essential.
I'd add to that, the need
to listen to everyone
is essential, making sure that
everybody's voice is heard.
That to me, is critical in
the diversity and inclusion
conversation.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: And,
Mick, same question to you.
What about in your org?
How does it implement?
MICK HODGINS: Yeah,
look, for me, I think,
we've got lots of
different people in my org,
and that's great.
So different people,
different backgrounds,
different cultures, different
perspectives, that's diversity.
I think we've got a
really diverse team.
I think when you think
about inclusion, inclusion
for me is about respect.
It's about creating a
culture, environment,
forum for people to
contribute an idea,
an opinion, whatever
that looks like.
But it's also about recognizing
that people's opinions will
be very different to yours,
and that's sort of OK,
and creating that space
for a healthy debate,
and for a healthy sense of
collective responsibility.
And I think that's really
important in the context
of if you don't
get to know people,
and you don't create that type
of environment, where people
feel sort of safe, then you can
really, really be inclusive.
And it's critical
for us as a business.
You talked about it earlier on.
If we don't drive the
inclusion agenda--
diversity is an
outcome, I agree.
If we don't draw the inclusion
agenda we're going to fail.
And it's being proven in
millions of different studies
that diverse and inclusive
teams just get better results
for businesses.
And you bring a
different perspective,
you make it a little
bit richer, and then
you get better results.
It's a really, really
straightforward equation
for me.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: And Ruth,
you mentioned in your talk
that sometimes the
conversation around diversity
can come across as a bit dull.
And I think everyone here
wants to do their bit,
and wants to get involved,
but sometimes life happens.
So what would be your
advice as to how can
we develop that well
from within to help out
and do the right thing.
RUTH HUNT: I think your quote at
the beginning was interesting.
So diversity is inviting
people, inclusion
is asking them to dance.
I think probably the next
stage of that is letting
people host their own parties.
You know, there's a kind of--
inviting back people
to dance is one thing.
Letting black people have
a party is quite another.
So I think it is about
changing our way of seeing.
And it is about
cultural and values.
And I think that
once people realize
that they are complicit
in creating the barriers,
then that will
naturally fade away.
The problem with
diversity is that you
get told a list of
things you can't do.
I'm sure Google was never
approached about this, promise.
But particularly in the
public sector, you know,
every police officer, do not
say this, do not say that,
do not say the other.
And that doesn't
change how they respond
when they see a Muslim woman
who's experienced a hate
crime to think differently
about how they're going
to have that conversation.
I think, to talk about
my mom for a moment
again, because she's on my mind
at the moment, when she came
round to the idea, and read
everything I'd ever written,
she was the dean of
nursing in [INAUDIBLE]..
And she started every
new year by saying turn
to the person next
to you, they'll
be your friend for life.
You may marry them or you may
enter a civil partnership.
Cardiff University is fully
committed to LGBT inclusion.
We're part of the
Stonewall program.
That's all she'd ever do.
And it just sent a very clear
signal to every undergraduate
that she wouldn't tolerate
homophobia on her watch
and that was OK.
And they all came out
as a result of that.
So these little
moments of indicating
your ally-ship, your
commitment, can actually
start making people feel more
comfortable in the environment.
I think the more people worry
about what they mustn't do,
the more frozen we become.
And we have something called
kind eyes at Stonewall, which
is presume people
are basically good,
and then help them along
the way to be better.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: We
have something similar,
which is assume good intent.
Similar to that, and I think you
made a really good point there,
everybody kind of needs to
just think about these things.
And it's really good to see
Mick our Liz joining us today.
You are both directors.
I'm sure you have
really busy schedules.
So what advice would you give to
people who want to get involved
but just can't find the time?
How does it work
for both of you?
MICK HODGINS: You
just got to make time.
Look, again, I sort of echo what
Ruth is saying in one sense,
that the more that
it becomes a pain,
the more that we've got
to do something about it.
So we can be vocal, and
we can give our support.
Or we can just really just get
on with it and get involved.
And we've got so many
different ways to get involved.
And down the years
in Google, we've
had so many programs that
have been successful.
We've run the Stretch Program,
Women Us, Take the Stage.
We've got all of
the stuff that we
do in Pride, senior citizens.
I'm going to give you a
shameless plug now by the way.
So the one thing that we're
working on at the moment,
as many of you might be aware
of, is Project Doorstep.
So you've heard me
stand on this stage
before and tell that
it's great to live
in this beautiful Google bubble.
And it's lovely to be in silicon
docs, and this is amazing.
And the business
is going forward.
And we're creating an ecosystem
here that's going forward.
And some of the most socially
disadvantaged parts of Dublin
are within one mile
of this building.
Really crazy stuff.
Like we have a resource
center down the road
that provides free services
on a volunteer basis
under one roof to
the local community,
including a creche
for unmarried mothers,
and drug rehabilitation
clinic, a job seeking clinic
to try to get young men and
young women back to work.
You name it, it's all
there under one roof.
And we never really
engage with those guys.
That's shameful, shameful.
So in March, we
launched a program
to engage with our
local neighbors,
because our
responsibility-- you use
this language with yourself--
our responsibility is
to ensure that as the whole
community moves forward,
nobody gets left behind.
We are part of this community,
inclusion is really important.
So we started in
March, 1st of May.
We went down to a
community parade
down in Ringsend and Irishtown.
We marched around the streets.
We hung out, beautiful
summer's day.
Actually, it was probably the
only day of summer in Ireland.
And the weather was fantastic.
We volunteered, kids,
bouncy castles, great fun.
And [INAUDIBLE] from
the [INAUDIBLE] team,
she may be here, she
might not be here--
oh, there you are.
[INAUDIBLE] is running the
senior citizens monthly program
in the org at the moment.
The first one was basically
described as this crazy disco.
But everybody had a bit of fun.
No agenda.
Just come in and let's
hang out with you.
And it's cooking up a storm.
Next week, we've got a thing
called the South Docs festival.
We've got about 15 or 20
different events happening
within a couple of
miles of the building.
So right here in
this auditorium,
we're going to have a
local kids talent show.
Bring your earplugs, right?
We're going to do walking tours.
We've got a fair in the square.
There's loads of stuff.
That for me is how
you get involved.
It's not a chore.
It's just part of what we do.
It's not an agenda.
And by the way, if you want
to volunteer, go/doorstep.
Forward
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: I've
already volunteered.
I'm really looking
forward to it.
LIZ CUNNINGHAM: I just wanted
to add one point to that.
I think they're all
brilliant initiatives, Mick,
and I'd encourage everybody
to get involved with them.
I think, particularly the
space people may struggle with,
how they can have an impact.
So we had our finance
directors and VPs offsite,
and we had a talk from
the finance BGN group.
And they were so
passionate about not
being afraid to get involved.
So people are
concerned in the space
about doing the wrong thing.
And it's so easy to say, well,
I'd rather not make a mistake,
and so I'm not going
to get involved.
And they were so encouraging
of the VP and director
group that were there to--
it's OK to make a mistake.
It's OK.
Even dipping your toe in.
So while all these initiatives
are great, Mick, and I really,
really encourage
people to get involved,
just look within your own team,
and wider team, your neighbors
around you, and see where you
can even make one small impact,
and not to worry about
doing the wrong thing.
Because doing something
means that you're
making a difference.
So that would be
my word of advice.
RUTH HUNT: And Stonewall
wouldn't have achieved anything
if we berated everybody every
time someone did something
wrong.
We'd be in the wrong business.
You know, the Premier League,
sometimes those conversations
we have, I do have to
go home and go-- what?
And the Church of
England, I mean
it's similar, similar
conversations.
And you just kind of
have to really just
be kind to each other, really.
But see that you have power.
You have power to
change the dynamic,
and that's what it's
all about really.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: You
mentioned about mistakes,
and I'm pretty sure that we
are having this conversation,
the awareness is
starting to happen.
We were chatting about
it at lunch as well,
using the right pronoun, or
saying the appropriate thing.
Have any of you ever made
a mistake in a workplace
where you said the wrong
term, or you weren't sure?
And if you did, what
lesson did you learn?
And how would you tell
others to deal with that?
LIZ CUNNINGHAM: I
never make mistakes.
MICK HODGINS: I try to
work out what a pronoun is.
LIZ CUNNINGHAM: That
was a hard question.
RUTH HUNT: Yes,
I've made mistakes.
Stonewall has 120 staff.
I'm 37.
That means I'm probably about
twice as old as most people
there, because we
obviously don't pay enough.
So there's lots
and lots of staff
who are constantly
exploring identity
in ways that has not even have
made it onto your internet.
So there's all sorts
of things happening.
And the odds of me getting
that right every single time
are pretty slim.
Non-binary pronouns
are quite complex.
So for somebody who wants
to get by they add them,
that confuses my
grammatical lexicon.
But that doesn't
mean it's not hard
for me to get my head around.
I just needed to think
about it for a bit longer,
and go, OK, that works.
Where are they going?
Where have they gone?
When are they coming back?
Is as straightforward
as when is she going?
and where is he going?
But people are very forgiving
if your intentions are good.
That's why Stonewall has
a philosophy of kind eyes.
And I think the more panic--
I've just read a
really good book
called, "Why I Stopped Talking
to White People About Racism".
And it really
explores-- read it.
It's really slim.
You can do it really quickly.
It really talks a lot about
how white people respond
really guiltily every time
they're racist in some way.
And it makes it all about them.
And actually, for
someone who's non-binary,
they don't want it to be all
about you, and your feelings,
and your anxiety, and
what you've done wrong,
and how that makes you
feel, and whether you
need to go to HR about it.
Just apologize and move on.
And I think that's--
don't keep doing it.
Be mindful.
But if you get it wrong,
just apologize and move on.
MICK HODGINS: Yeah, I agree.
Anyone who's in
this audience who
works with me knows
that sometimes when
you're really, really busy,
you go from one meeting
to another meeting--
I only talked about this
recently and people I work
with have coined
this phrase as drive
by meetings, where you
arrive in, ask a question,
answer it yourself, move
on, job done, right?
And I did a lot of this.
And I'm very personally aware of
how I'm trying to change that.
So I get it wrong all the
time, I absolutely assure you.
But I think the
most important thing
is that we're all human beings.
I've got a life
outside of Google.
I've got two kids.
Things can be stressful.
We have crazy jobs.
And you're going
to get it wrong.
You're going to mess it up.
You're going to make mistakes.
But I think as
Ruth said, you got
to acknowledge it and put it
right as quickly as you can.
However, you cannot be a
slave to political correctness
and putting it right.
That's when it becomes
a real pain in the ass
and you turn it into
something that it's not.
RUTH HUNT: And it
makes no difference.
It doesn't change culture.
And it doesn't help.
So it just kind of
reduces all of us.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: And you
mentioned as well in your
or the majority is women.
LIZ CUNNINGHAM: All women.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: I spent two
years working in engineering,
or hiring for them, and as
all of you probably are aware,
women are a minority in
the engineering world.
So you also mentioned that you
have been part of a minority
group, whether it be your
gender, sexual orientation,
ethnicity.
How was that experience, and
would you like to share it?
LIZ CUNNINGHAM: Yeah, so
women make great tax people.
That's why we've--
I see some of my team
here, so shout out to them.
I don't experience it often.
Or if I do, I sort of--
we've got a very
technical background.
And I always revert back to my
core job and my core training.
So that makes it easy.
So I kind of go I'm here
not because I'm a woman
or whatever, I'm here
because I'm here to do a job.
But I wanted to share
one example of where--
and I think it goes to
your previous question--
where I made a mistake.
And I made a mistake
about myself.
I was on the advanced
leadership lab directors.
You've done that,
Mick, haven't you?
So we do this scavenger
hunt, but it's
run by a team who trained Nasa,
so it's a serious scavenger
hunt.
And I was the only
woman in the group.
And it was at a time when Google
was buying a lot of companies.
So there was a lot of CEOs from
companies that we had acquired,
and a lot of engineers, and
a couple of sales people.
And I don't know, I
was in a funny space
because there was
stuff going on at home.
I had to organize--
I don't know if any, for you
in the audience have children,
but you know those
Christmas boxes
they do for the [INAUDIBLE].
So I forgot about
the Christmas box
and my husband was
in a bit of a panic,
and I said look, just go and
grab like some of her stuff
and put it in.
She's not going to notice.
She has too much stuff already.
So some poor child got a lot
of my child's second-hand stuff
for Christmas.
But anyway, it's fine.
So I was in that kind
of funny mind set,
I didn't listen to
the instructions.
I was sort of in a funny mood.
But anyway, to cut
a long story short,
I literally set myself
up at the bag carrier.
So everybody had their role.
So I took the very traditional
female role of well,
I'll carry the bag, like
literally, physically
carry the bag.
And so with had these really
complicated clues to work out.
And I just didn't do anything
for the first couple of clues.
And then eventually I
was like, these guys
actually have no clue
what they're doing.
So one guy was [INAUDIBLE],, one
guy was doing something else.
And it was all about their
roles and their jobs.
And they were very, very--
and not offending any men
in the audience, but they were
very clear about their role.
I made the mistake of
going well, I just work--
I just take whatever
they don't take.
And so I really let myself down.
And so, eventually,
because I've got
quite a technical
background, I worked out
that I was actually
working out the clues.
And so there was one
particular clue--
and I was so frustrated, because
one of the rules of the game
was you had to stay together.
And I was like, I am not
following those idiots
up that hill.
I am sorry, I'm done.
So I did a time out with the
facilitator, and I said, look,
can you somehow intervene here.
I said, OK, I'll intervene
in this particular case.
And so they said, look, Liz
is right, you guys are wrong.
And the clue's across the water.
So we worked out the clue.
Then four or five clues.
And eventually, I became the
sort of the clue worker-outer,
or whatever.
So we won the thing, and we high
fived, and it was all amazing.
And the facilitator turned
round and said to the guys
why did it take you so
long to listen to Liz?
And they were like, well,
we had to wait and see
how many clues she worked out.
And then when she worked so
many, we listened to her.
Now, my reaction to
that was, oh, my gosh.
And they felt really bad.
They were really torn, and they
said they realized that they
weren't-- they learned that
maybe they weren't listening
to their team,
and in particular,
listening to the
women on their team.
Now my immediate reaction was--
I'm not a great listener--
I was like crap, I'm probably
not listening to people either.
And now I know what it
feels like to have to--
taken so long to be listened to.
So there's so many
lessons in that.
I'm not sure I'm
answering your question.
But I wanted to make sure to
get that example out there.
I let myself down as well.
So I'm not saying that
those men singled me out.
I think part of the problem
was I set myself up as well.
I didn't think I was worthy
of having a role on that team,
for whatever reason, whatever
bias was going on in my head.
I definitely
contributed to that.
So anyway that was my
director leadership lab story.
MICK HODGINS: That was great.
Note to self, on
the next course,
find the gay community to
sort out the scavenger hunt.
I've been lucky
enough, I've worked
in lots of different countries
during the years, worked
at different organizations.
Before I joined Google, I
worked for a wines and spirits
business, a large multinational.
I spent a bit of time down
in South Africa in Cape Town.
So I joined what was
a pretty early phase
business, and 100% white male.
All of them Afrikaans.
They would speak Afrikaans
first and English second.
It gets better.
Many of them had fought together
in the South African defense
forces in the Angolan
war in the 1980s.
They would barbecue
together and [INAUDIBLE],,
and hang out together.
And then this Irish guy, who
was like early to mid-20s,
arrived down to help
them with their strategy
and show them how to
grow their business.
So that just didn't really
work out at the start.
I was a novelty for
maybe about eight weeks.
There were a lot of,
look, the Irish guy.
His skin is pale
blue type of jokes.
And many potato comments.
And you're in the situation
where you sort of laugh it off.
But you're thinking, Christ,
this is just not good enough
for us.
It was really,
really uncomfortable.
I would go to social events with
them, and after a few beers,
they would go back into
their native language.
And they'd speak for two hours.
And I'd just be
on the periphery.
And every time that
there was a laugh,
you'd sort of feel
the laugh, because you
didn't know whether or
not they were actually
cracking a joke about you
or laughing about you.
So that was really
tough, and not cool.
I learned a lot from
that experience.
I think the way I sort of
dealt with that over time
though was to try and just
get to know people as people,
and always have your voice
heard, whether or not
it's in that meeting or
that group environment,
or whether you can
find a way to get
your voice heard afterwards.
Just always make sure
they respect you.
And then the novelty wore off.
They moved on to
different things.
Men like shiny stuff, you
know we're very simple beings.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: I believe
at some point in our lives
we've all been part of a
majority or minority group.
And when we are in
the majority group,
it is our responsibility
to advocate on
behalf of those who are
not in the majority.
So thank you so much for
sharing your examples.
Ruth, one question that I
would have is obviously,
as somebody who you said
you are a campaigner,
and you've done some really
good campaigning for the LGBT
plus issues, I heard at
Pride this year-- obviously,
I've been going for the
last three years-- really,
really good fun, and just
really great to be out there.
Some of the feedback
that I heard
was that the LGBT plus community
wasn't very happy about how
the straight people were
taking over and just showing
their presence.
So I mean, just from
your point of view,
is that a valid thing to say?
RUTH HUNT: No, and to
be honest, as we're
in this confidential space,
the concern about Pride
is more than that.
So what's happening
with pride is
that lots and lots
of corporates turn up
to Pride who've never
done any active LGBT work.
So they hire a van that
cost 30,000 pounds.
They put 200 people on that
bus who got drunk on champagne,
quite openly, while the
community groups can barely
afford to send their
youth group along.
And it seems like such
a tone deaf PR disaster,
I don't really understand
why they're struggling.
Other groups, other companies
who march, who literally walk,
go down fine.
Or if you want to go on a
bus, give over half your bus
to a community group.
In my mind, I think
it's quite simple.
So what the community is
talking about in terms
of straight people come
into Pride is about that.
It's about people
coming on a bus.
It used to be the
fact that used to get
shouted and spatted at at
Pride by straight people.
So now the fact that there
are straight people marching
and celebrating is great.
We sponsor UK Black Pride,
which is the next day,
that has a budget of 7-1/2
grand to the 750,000 of Pride
in London, and really struggles.
And the way in which
organizations and companies
work with UK Black Pride,
Pride for LGBT people of color
is really indicative.
So there's a lot going on,
on lots of different issues.
But in Stonewall's
view, there are far more
heterosexual people than LGBT.
Number two, two pints, and
we're all on a journey.
And the more people
you can get involved--
the more people you can
get involved, the better,
to my mind.
And that's always been
how Stonewall's worked.
Can I just share
a story my sexism?
I know we're
running out of time.
So when I took
over as chief exec,
we had this moment where the
chair, the treasurer, who's
on our board, and my MD
and me were all women.
And I said on the board we're
a women's lead organization.
And one of the men on the
board was so concerned about
that I had to write a
full paper scrutinizing
our approach to recruitment, why
I was not demonstrating gender
bias in any of my
recruitment or restructuring,
how I was going to
ensure that men felt
able to be themselves
and welcome
in this new matriarchal
dominant organization
and give myself
targets around that.
I had to do this full scrutiny.
We'd been a male lead
organization for 15 years.
I had two weeks of a
handover where it was women.
And it absolutely--
it really saddened me.
And it really frustrated
me, considering
the amount of sexism
I was getting in the--
I just thought this is
your moment, trustees,
to shut up and back up.
And instead actually you've held
me to account about something
that is meaningless.
So there we are.
That's off record.
[LAUGHTER]
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: Thank you,
thank you so much for sharing.
MICK HODGINS: Not anymore.
RUTH HUNT: No, I know.
Just--
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY:
Things are changing.
Change is what makes
us better, right?
RUTH HUNT: Yeah, exactly.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY:
So, I would like
to open it to the audience
for some questions.
So please raise your hand and
wait for the mic to get to you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, can you hear me?
Great.
You talked about the
fallacy of meritocracy,
and I think here at Google,
while hopefully we're
very much ahead of
a lot of companies,
otherwise the world
is in deep trouble,
we are still deeply
flawed in that sense.
So you mentioned that
that is a problem.
But what could be the solution?
What is the fair way
to evaluate people?
RUTH HUNT: I think there's macro
and micro responses to that.
The macro responses to that
are about actually getting
into your local schools
and helping them improve,
and helping kids who may not
have those circumstances do
better, so that when they get
to your recruitment stage,
they're on a more
level playing field.
So there's a kind of
macro issue there.
Looking at degree
programs, entrances,
making sure that there's
more scholarships
available for young people
going into university.
Because we've adopted
an American approach
to higher education,
without any of the packages
around that to manage that.
It's a kind of messed up system.
I think in terms
of recruitment, it
is about measuring
potential as well as skills.
It's about one on
one interviews,
repeated, rather than a panel.
Because panels always reinforce
each other's unconscious bias,
unconscious bias, continually.
One on one conversations
make people
more likely to talk
about their feelings
and how they're
going to perform.
But also, it is about
more internal recognition
that there is
potential in people.
So what I often see
in organizations
is that the majority
of [INAUDIBLE] staff
are entry level
posts, secretarial,
or administrative roles.
And nobody ever talks to
them about the possibility
of maybe doing
some in-house work,
and moving on to something else.
I remember talking to
someone yesterday who said,
I don't even know what her
educational background is.
It's like, well
you don't need to.
She's been a really good
assistant to your team.
Let's find a way of
actually bringing her in.
We typecast people
really easily.
And in something
as big as Google,
there is enough room to
actually think differently.
So at Stonewall,
we've actively worked
with our [INAUDIBLE] staff who
are in more junior positions
and sent them on more
specific training courses,
but also made sure
they can shadow me.
So they've been shadowing
me for a couple of weeks,
getting access to my
inbox, things like that.
So really just breaking
down some of those rules
around some of those things can
be a big help as a sure answer.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: I saw
some hands in the back.
Do you mind throwing it?
We all saw the health
and safety video.
AUDIENCE: Actually, I'll
give it to Philip first.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Ruth, thank you
very much for coming in today.
It was a fantastic talk.
My question is
specifically about what
is increasingly seeming to
become the silent B in LGBT,
which is bisexuality.
So it's obviously quite a hard
thing to represent in media,
and it's a relatively
hard thing to discuss
in corporate environments,
because any corporation sort of
wants boxes to put people in.
And it's much easier
to have straight
and gay than bisexuality.
How do we overcome
that as a challenge
and make sure that
we're putting people,
if we have to categorize
them, on a scale,
rather than just in a box.
RUTH HUNT: So I think
it is that difference
between scale and a
box is hard for people
who are new to the journey.
Stonewall has done bi-only role
model programs, run bi people.
So we're developing
quite a critical mass
of people who identify
as bisexual who
work for corporations, including
men, which is really exciting.
So some of our old bi stuff
was very female dominated
and heavy, for lots
of different reasons.
But more men are
getting involved now.
I do think-- Stonewall changed
its tagline from the lesbian
and gay charity,
under my predecessor,
to acceptance without exception.
So I don't really talk about
words at all like lesbian, gay,
bisexual, and tran.
It's all about where are
you at on your journey
and let's accept you.
I think that the media really
struggle in terms of bi phobia.
And I think that there's
a lot to be done in terms
of challenging bi phobia.
All our data points show
that bi people experience
greater incidence of poor
mental health and well-being,
compared to lesbian and gay men.
And corporations have been doing
this work for a long time well.
Gay men are the most
satisfied group,
according to monitoring terms,
compared to any other group.
And you test it all
down, and then bisexuals
are at the bottom of it.
So more bi specific events,
more bi specific conversations,
more bi role models, encouraging
people to tell their stories
and their experiences
is really important.
Because young people
are very rarely
identifying as either
lesbian and gay now.
All our youth work--
I'm a bit old fashioned for
being a standard lesbian.
So your new recruitment
drive is going
to be much more bi centered
than lesbian and gay centered.
So that is going to have to
just shift in time as well.
MICK HODGINS: Food for thought.
Just looking to see
where our HR and hiring
people are in the audience.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's not me.
MICK HODGINS: It's
real food for thought.
AUDIENCE: Ruth, what's one
thing we could all do today
and when we leave to make sure
we don't leave others behind?
RUTH HUNT: So find three
people with less power than you
and go and share.
Because by being in this
room, you have more power.
By working for Google,
you have more power.
Go and volunteer.
Go and ask somebody.
Go and find three junior
people in this organization who
are feeling a bit lost and
mentor them, and show up,
and make yourself
available to help them.
Everybody thinks about
themselves in relation
to the things that are
going less well for them.
I think if you start
looking beyond,
that's really important.
So I mentor two young
women who are refugees,
who live in Bethnal
Green, who are just
trying to do their GCSEs.
And I meet them once
a month and we talk.
And I tell them to go along to
meetings at their local labor
party and get involved.
It doesn't matter.
People need to know
the rules of how
to get involved in something.
People exclude themselves
based on not knowing the rules.
And I think if you
share your power,
you can do amazing things.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MICK HODGINS: And that fear
is-- just too add to that,
that fear is illusory.
It's just totally the
fear of the unknown.
RUTH HUNT: Exactly.
MICK HODGINS: So if you don't go
and dip your toe in the water,
you just-- you're
never going to know.
RUTH HUNT: You need some help.
You need someone to hold your
hand through that sometimes.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY: Do we have
time for one more question
perhaps?
This question in the back there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So I just have a quick question
related to all how can we do
things that are-- like how
do we behave when we have
conversations with people who
think completely different,
who are not so open
minded, who don't--
because we all come from
different countries and places,
and it's all great that
we think that we're so
open minded and Google and
a bunch of other companies.
But when we go back home or
and we have this really--
and we talk about what we
talk about here, or like all
the events we
have, and how do we
have those hard conversations
when people just start
making fun of these things, and
just make jokes, in societies
where things are
not open minded,
and 80% of the population
against all these things?
RUTH HUNT: So I was
in Poland last week.
And I don't talk about
the multi nature gender
identity and the
inclusion of FUCO
and people's changing
sense of life.
I talk about human rights,
and I talk about hate crime,
and I talk about wasted
talent and potential.
So to a certain extent,
it is about working
with people where they're at.
I mean, Premier League, I
don't mention bisexual identity
with the Premier League.
I talk about gay footballers
being scared about scoring.
It is a little bit about making
sure you match your audience
and then taking it through.
A lot of the work we're
doing at Stonewall
is working with Diaspora,
from some of those countries,
and bringing them together, and
helping them talk about some
of the ways in which they can
develop new conversations.
So bringing 36 gay and
straight people from Russia
into a room, who
now live in Britain,
is really helping
those people kind
of talk about these things.
We did some great work
with teenage girls
from evangelical
Pentecostal communities,
who are just awesome.
They're just amazing.
So really kind of thinking about
what level of empathy exists.
So we've just come
from Armenia, where
we've worked with women's
groups on employment rights.
And then they talk
about LGBT rights.
But we've gone in
talking about gender.
We've not talked about
sexual orientation or gender
identity at all.
So going at the level that
we're at and accepting that,
and just doing the best we can.
Because the last thing that
helps is British and European
imperialistic lecturing
to other communities.
And the trouble I have with
the conservative government
in Britain is that we're
going on to other countries,
going we're really good at this.
It's like well 20 years
ago, you were rubbish.
And it would be more helpful
if you talked about the fact
that you were a bit
rubbish 20 years ago,
and how you've made that
change, to pretending
that you've got
something to patronize
these black people about.
So it's kind of really
understanding our role in that,
I think.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANAM AKHTAR TREACY:
All right, so
thank you so much to all of
you for joining us today.
I learned a lot of things.
Lots of great quotes as
well, and a motivation
to do a little bit more
and help this cause.
Thanks everyone for joining us.
And a big round of applause
for all our panelists.
[APPLAUSE]